Jetzt.
Guten Tag, mein Name ist Dr. Sackchi.
Ich bin der zuständige Arzt für Sie auf dieser Station.
Bevor wir Ihre aktuellen Beschwerden besprechen, bräuchte ich ein paar persönliche Daten von Ihnen.
Sind Sie damit einverstanden?
Guten Abend, ja, natürlich.
So, wie heißen Sie?
Mein Name ist Volker.
Volker?
Zerke.
Können Sie bitte Ihren Vornamen und Namen bestätigen?
Aber natürlich. Mein Vornamen ist Volker.
Vogelv, Otto, Ludwig, Karl, Emil, Richard, Volker.
Ja.
Nachname ist Zerke, Zeppelin, Emil, Heinrich, Richard, KW Karl und E wie Emil.
Emil, Zerke.
Zerke. Ja, Herr Zerke.
Jawohl.
Herr Zerke, wie alt sind Sie?
Ich bin 42 Jahre alt.
Und wie groß sind Sie?
1,74 Meter.
Wie klein wohl.
Und zurzeit wie viel wiegen Sie?
Also, okay, Sie haben nach meinem Gewicht gefragt. Ich bin 95 Kilo im Moment.
95.
95, ja.
Das ist eine gute Frage. Wie heißt Ihr Hausarzt?
Das ist Dr. Heinrich.
Heinrich.
Heinrich, genau. Der ist in der Bahnhofstraße 12.
Straße 12, okay.
Wen können wir kontaktieren im Notfall zum Angehörigen?
Meine Frau.
Frau.
Okay. Herr Zerke, was führt Sie heute zu uns? Was kann ich für Sie tun?
Also ich sehe seit ein paar Tagen schlecht.
Ja.
Das hat angefangen, das ist etwas auf beiden Seiten etwas verschwommen und ich merke, dass ich schlechter sehe und woher das kommt.
Schlechter sehen.
Ja.
Und Sie haben gesagt, dass seit ein paar Tage.
Zum Beispiel fünf Tage oder zehn Tage. Was meinen Sie?
Also ca. seit fünf Tagen.
Fünf Tage.
Nur verschwommen oder haben Sie noch etwas andere Beschwerden?
Also andere Beschwerden, ja, das kam noch hinzu.
Also ich dachte, das geht wieder vorbei, aber ich habe so ganz trockenen Mund und ich habe das Gefühl, ich muss viel Wasser trinken.
Ich bin müde und ich fühle mich einfach nicht gut, ich schlafe schlecht.
Ich weiß nicht, was das ist.
Ich mache mir so langsam Sorge.
Ja, trinken Sie viel oder?
Gar nicht.
Ich habe oft einen trockenen Mund und manchmal habe ich das Gefühl, dass meine Zunge im Mund an den Gaumen klebt.
Okay.
Ich muss immer wieder, ich habe immer eine Flasche Wasser dabei, viel Wasser trinken.
Und diese Beschwerden seit ca. fünf Tagen?
Ja, ja, genau.
Und haben Sie zum Beispiel in letzter Zeit auch zum Beispiel häufige Infekte bekommen oder?
Ja, immer wieder Infekte, also kreepale Infekte.
Ich dachte, es ist jetzt wieder Zeit, dass es normal ist und habe mir jetzt nichts dabei gedacht.
Aber ja, ich dachte, das ist normal.
Okay, und auch gehen Sie häufig als Früher zur Toilette?
Ja, das stimmt.
Das ist auch jetzt seit ungefähr einer Woche.
Ich habe das Gefühl, dass ich öfter Wasser lassen muss.
Und ja, das ist verstärkt.
Das stimmt.
Ja, wollte ich auch sagen.
Okay.
Und in letzter Zeit haben Sie Gewicht mehr verloren oder?
Eigentlich nicht.
Also ich habe jetzt über die letzten vier, fünf Jahre sehr viel Gewicht zugenommen, ca. 20 Kilo.
20 Kilo?
Seit fünf Jahren ungefähr.
Aber gut, ich nehme auch sehr viele Antidepressiva, weil ich ein bisschen Depressionen habe.
Ich würde sagen, das kommt daher.
Aber abgenommen habe ich, das wäre schön, wenn ich abnehmen könnte.
Diese Depression, wann war das festgestellt?
Ach, das ist schon seit ungefähr acht Jahren.
Und nehmen Sie dagegen irgendwelche Medikamente?
Ja, ja, ich nehme da regelmäßig.
Im Moment habe ich zwei Medikamente.
Und wissen Sie die Name?
Ach Gott, ist mir jetzt entfallen.
Aber irgendwas mit Bupropion, glaube ich, war das eine.
Bupropion.
Genau.
Und das andere war, oh je, ich weiß nicht mehr, Venlafaxin.
Ich habe so viele geändert, jetzt weiß ich nicht mehr.
Venlafaxin.
Ja, ich brauche Venlafaxin.
Wissen Sie die Dosierung, oder?
Nein, habe ich vergessen.
Gucken Sie mal, das ändert sich immer wieder bei mir.
Okay, kein Problem.
Herr Zirke, haben Sie Probleme beim Stuhlgang?
Nein, das eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay, und haben Sie Schlafstörungen?
Was haben Sie?
Schlafstörungen.
Schlafstörungen, ja, ja.
Das ist einer der Gründe, warum ich Medikamente nehme.
Ich kann einschlafen, aber ich kann nicht durchschlafen.
Das heißt, ich werde...
Durchschlafen.
Durchschlafprobleme.
Ich werde in der Nacht wach und kann dann schlecht wieder einschlafen.
Haben Sie Herzrasen, Brustschmerz, Herzklopfen oder Atemnot?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, nein.
Und wie ist Ihr Appetit?
Essen Sie gut, ja, oder?
Ja, also das ist ein Problem, ja.
Aber es ist zu gut.
Ja, natürlich.
Okay.
Und haben Sie Schüttelfrost, Schweißausbruch oder Nachtschweiß?
Nein, das habe ich nicht, nein.
Aber was ein bisschen auffällt, ist, dass ich mich schlecht konzentrieren kann.
Und dass ich ein bisschen vergesslich geworden bin, ja.
Seit wann haben Sie diese Beschwerden, diese Konzentration, Probleme oder...
Das geht schon länger, vielleicht seit zwei, drei Monaten.
Haben Sie Verdauungprobleme?
Ja, nicht immer, aber manchmal.
Also ich bekomme manchmal Blähungen und manchmal so leichten Durchfall, aber nicht so oft.
Entschuldigung, gibt es auch Verstopfungen oder nur Durchfall?
Sehr selten, ja.
Durchfall, aber Verstopfungen habe ich eigentlich nicht so.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Grundschmerzerkrankungen?
Wie gesagt, Depressionen.
Ja, natürlich.
Und ansonsten eigentlich nicht, nein.
Okay.
Und haben Sie irgendwelche, außer diese zwei Medikamente, regelmäßig irgendwelche Medikamente eingenommen, oder?
Nein, regelmäßig nicht, nein.
Ab und zu wenn ich mal Schmerzen habe, nämlich Ibuprofen, aber sonst nicht.
Ibuprofen?
Okay.
Und sind Sie schon einmal operiert worden?
Nein, bisher nicht, nein.
Haben Sie irgendwelche Allergie?
Also gegen Medikamente jetzt nicht, aber gegen Pollen.
Pollenallergien?
Ja.
Und wie äußert sich?
Och, das ist immer ganz schlimm. Meine Augen tränen, meine Nase läuft, ich muss oft niesen und bin müde, die Schlafstörungen werden schlechter.
Und da muss ich immer Medikamente nehmen und dann geht es einigermaßen.
Okay. Und welche Medikamente?
Zetirizin.
Bestimmte Medikamente, oder?
Bei Bedarf?
Genau, ja.
Und Herr Zelke, rauchen Sie?
Nein, nein.
Trinken Sie Alkohol?
Oh, sehr, sehr selten, eigentlich fast nie.
Was meinen Sie zum Beispiel einmal pro Woche oder einmal pro Monat?
Wenn ich mal auf eine Einladung bin, auf ein Geburtstag vielleicht, oder wenn man mal abends mal zum Essen weggeht, aber ansonsten nicht.
Und ich möchte wieder, ja, am aktuellen Beschwerden zurückkommen.
Und haben Sie Kribbeln oder Taubheißgefühl oder Kribbeln?
Bisher noch nicht, nein, ist mir nicht aufgefallen, nein.
Das ist eine Routinefrage, bitte nehmen Sie nicht persönlich.
Hatten Sie oder haben Sie Kontakt mit irgendwelchen Drogen?
Oh nein, nein.
Sind Sie zuständig gegen Kinder, Kinderheit, Krankheiten und Corona geimpft?
Ja, also mein Haushalt schaut sich das immer an, also meine Impfungen sind komplett.
Okay. Und waren Sie in letzter Zeit im Ausland?
Nein, nein. Ich war zuletzt einmal in Frankreich, kurz beruflich, aber sonst nicht.
Und in Ihrer Familie gibt es bekannte chronische Erkrankungen? Wie Bluthoch und Zuckerkrankheit?
Ja, meine Mutter hatte Diabetes. Die ist leider vor zwei Jahren verstorben und hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Seit? Vor drei Jahren?
Vor zwei Jahren, vor zwei Jahren ist meine Mutter gestorben, sie hatte einen Schlaganfall.
Aber sie hatte auch Diabetes, lange Jahre, und mein Vater hatte hohen Blutdruck.
Ihre Mutter bekam die Tablette gegen diese?
Das weiß ich nicht. Und hatte auch Insulin gehabt.
Beide, Tablette und Insulin.
Ja, ich glaube, sie hat beides gehabt.
Und ja, Ihr Vater lebt noch?
Mein Vater lebt noch, der hat hohen Blutdruck, und soweit ich weiß, ging er da auch Medikamente.
Haben Sie die Schwestern?
Nein.
Sie haben schon gesagt, Sie sind verheiratet. Haben Sie Kinder?
Ich habe zwei Kinder, ja. Die eine ist zehn Jahre alt und die andere sieben.
Sind Sie gesund?
Ja, ja. Bis hiernächst ist alles gut.
Was machen Sie beruflich her, Serge?
Ich bin Logistiker. Ich bin bei einer großen Firma, das würde Logistik im Lager zuständig, ich bin Abteilungsleiter.
Lagerabteilung?
Also genau, Lager. Und bin halt dort für die Koordination und die Logistik zuständig.
Okay. Und haben Sie Stress bei der Arbeit?
Ja, natürlich Stress, das gibt es immer.
Treiben Sie Sport, Herr Zerke?
Nein, leider nicht. Das wäre schön.
Mirka, kannst du ein bisschen leiser sein?
Eine Lumenmärze?
Herr Zerke, besuchen Sie regelmäßig Ihre Urologen?
Nein. Bisher war ich jetzt nicht beim Urologen, nein.
Aber das ist sehr wichtig, nach der 40 Jahre, man muss mindestens einmal pro Jahr.
Ja, echt? Aber bisher habe ich jetzt nie das Gefühl gehabt oder das Bedürfnis, zum Urologen zu gehen.
Als Vorsorge.
Als Vorsorge?
Ja, als Vorsorge.
Wenn Sie das empfehlen, Herr Doktor, dann können wir.
Ja, natürlich, das ist sehr wichtig für Sie.
Aber Sie sind halt als Mann sehr ungern zum Urologen, gell?
Ja, Herr Zerke, gerade bin ich mit meinen aller Fragen fertig.
Und was gibt es noch, das hinzufügen möchten Sie?
Vielen Dank. Das macht mir Sorgen natürlich, diese Symptome.
Insbesondere, dass eine Sehschwäche da aufgetreten ist plötzlich.
Und deswegen bin ich zu Ihnen gekommen.
Ja, natürlich, wir machen alle. Gibt es noch zwei Schritte?
Zuerst werde ich Sie körperlich untersuchen, danach etwas Blut.
Danach nehme ich etwas Blut Ihnen ab und so wie ein paar operative Untersuchungen durchführen.
Machen Sie das alles noch heute Abend, oder?
Natürlich, ja. Innerhalb, ich glaube, innerhalb von zwei oder drei Stunden können wir es schaffen.
Oh, das ist gut. Lass es heute.
Wenn alle Befunde vorliegen, dann bespreche ich mit meinem Arzt, Oberarzt.
Und dann komme ich Ihnen zurück und wir sprechen für Vortage.
Ja, das ist gut. Mein Nachbar hat schon gesagt, dass Sie ein guter Arzt sind und dass das Krankenhaus auch sehr gut ist.
Vielen Dank.
Dankeschön.
Bitte schön.
Ein bisschen schade, dass ich hier sein kann.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Bitte schön, ja, natürlich.
Sie haben schon gesagt, dass Sie Depressionen haben, aber ist Ihnen in den letzten Tagen aufgefallen, dass Sie sehr schnell gereis reagieren?
Ja, das habe ich immer wieder, aber auch für dich war das jetzt nicht. Nein.
Und wann haben Sie zuletzt Blut abnehmen lassen?
Oh, das ist schon länger, vor circa einem Jahr.
Danke schön.
Darf ich?
Bitte schön, natürlich.
Haben Sie Veränderungen an den Augen bemerkt in letzter Zeit?
Im hervorretenden Augenabfeld?
Ach so, was jetzt nicht, nein. Nur diese Sehverschlechterung jetzt.
Und haben Sie Schwellungen im Hals bemerkt?
Schwellungen? Nein.
Danke.
Mein Hausarzt hat gesagt vor einem Jahr, dass meine Zuckerwerte sehr grenzwertig sind, also dass dieser Langzuckerwert da war, so bei 6,1.
Darf ich eine Frage stellen?
Aber natürlich, ja.
Haben Sie bemerkt die überriegende Urin?
Also ja, so ein bisschen. Der riecht jetzt stärker und er ist so ein bisschen dunkler.
Dunkler. Danke schön.
Darf ich fragen?
So, wir können gerne weitermachen.
Ja.
Darf ich fragen?
Ist da noch eine Frage?
Ja.
Haben Sie Schmerzen in irgendwelchen Körperteilen?
Wo Schmerzen?
In irgendwelchen Körperteilen. Haben Sie Schmerzen?
Also zusätzlich Schmerzen habe ich jetzt nicht, nein.
Haben Sie früher ähnliche Beschwerde gehabt?
Nein, nein. Deswegen hat mich das jetzt etwas verängstigt, weil ich das erste Mal jetzt so habe, ja.
Ich habe nicht gehört. Leiden Sie unter Fieber, Schüttelfrost oder ...
Nein, nein, bisher nicht, nein.
Ok, danke.
Danke schön.
So, wollen wir fortfahren?
Ja.
Entschuldigung, kann ich fragen?
Noch eine Frage.
Haben Sie Haarausfall?
Ja, Sie sehen, ich habe ganz wenige Haare, aber das sind noch länger. Ist nicht gesagt.
Entschuldigung, darf ich nochmal eine Frage stellen?
Ja, natürlich.
Hat Ihre Frau bemerkt, dass Sie einen überriechenden Mund haben?
So ein bisschen, ja. Sie hatten vorgestern darauf angesprochen, dass der Atem etwas stärker riecht. Das stimmt, ja.
Aber das ist neu, hatte ich früher.
Früher hatte ich.
Ok, bevor nächste Fragen kommen, soll ich vielleicht ein paar Ergebnisse für den untersuchenden Doktor sagen?
Ok.
Was die Ergebnisse sind. Sie haben Blut abgenommen.
Ja.
Nüchtern Blutzucker 430.
430, ok.
Nieren 1,2.
Rear Zinin.
Leberwerte ganz leicht angestiegen.
GOT, GPT.
Der Rest war soweit eigentlich in Ordnung, ja.
302 oder? Nüchtern Blutzucker.
430.
Ok, das könnte eine Diabetik Ketoacidos sein.
Und dann müssen wir ja sofort an Monitor anschließen.
Jetzt die Laborergebnisse.
Jetzt Übergabe an den Oberarzt.
Sie stellen Ihre Verdachtstheaknote und dann machen Sie einen Therapievorschlag.
Ok.
Ich bin bereit, ich bin der Oberarzt.
Ja, guten Tag Herr Oberarzt.
Ich habe heute einen neuen Patienten aufgenommen und möchte Ihnen ihn gerne vorstellen.
Haben Sie kurze Zeit?
Ja, Sie haben immer interessante Patienten, das freut mich. Bitte schön.
Herr Volkart Zerke, 42 Jahre alt, 1,74 Meter groß, 5,90 Kilo schwer.
Ich stelle Sie heute bei uns vor.
Der Patient klagte über seit 5 Tagen bestehende langsam aufgetretene Sehstörungen in Form von Verschwungen.
Begleitet berichtet er über trockenen Mund, Mülligkeit, Fatigu, Polakissuri, Polydipsie und Infektanfähigkeit.
Zusätzlich gab der Patient eine Gewichtszunahme von 20 Kilo innerhalb eines Jahres.
Nein.
Entschuldigung.
In der vegetativen Anamnese besteht ab und zu eine bestehende Diarrhohe und eine Depression bedingter Insomnie.
Als Anfallerkrankungen besteht eine Depression, die mit Bupropion und Fenlawaxin behandelt seit acht Jahren.
Behandelt wird?
Ja, behandelt wird.
Okay.
Er hat eine Prolenallergie, die sich als Augen, Tränen, Niesen und Renitokonjunktivität äußert.
Renokonjunktivität, genau.
Ja, Renokonjunktivität äußert.
Und dagegen nimmt er Z-Risin ein.
Okay.
Und er ist nicht Raucher und trinkt sehr selten oder gelegentlich Alkohol.
Papa!
Er kontaktiert nicht mit Drogen.
In der Familienanamnese liegt die Mutter an Diabetes-Melitis Typ 1, aber Insulin.
Typ 2.
Ja, in der Nesterseite benutzen wir auch manche Patienten in der Nesterseite.
Vor zwei Jahren ist sie an Apoplex verstorben.
Der Vater leidet an Arteriella-Hypertonie und ich habe vergessen, ob die gut eingestellt sind oder nicht.
Aber ...
Man mannt.
Ja.
Und er hat keine Geschwister.
Er ist verheiratet und habe zwei gesunde Kinder.
Ein im Alter von 10 und andere im Alter von 7.
Er arbeitet als Logistiker in einer Firma, in der Lagerabteilung.
Und er hat viel Stress bei der Arbeit.
Okay.
Meine Anamnese ist das.
Und aufgrund der Symptomatik habe ich den Verdacht auf eine Diabetes-Melitis.
Dafür sprechen ja Polakysurie, Polydipsy, Sechstörungen und Infektanfähigkeit.
Haben Sie Laboruntersuchungen gemacht?
Nein.
Ja, da muss ich natürlich zuerst das Blut abnehmen.
Ich habe in der Laborart.
Ah, okay.
Dann je nach dieser Befunde.
Ich spreche je nach dieser Befunde.
Und ich habe schon Laborergebnisse bekommen.
Und das Nüchthensucker ist leider 430.
Und ja, das ist eine Diabetes-Ketoacidos.
Haben Sie Blutgase auch gemacht?
Nein, leider nein.
Dann führe ich sofort durch, auch diese Blutgasanalyse.
Und natürlich, um den Verdacht zu bestätigen,
zuerst werde ich die Patientkörperliche Untersuchung.
Dann sofort eine Blut.
Wir haben schon abgenommen.
Und Urin haben Sie auch untersucht?
Ja, Urin auf jeden Fall.
Was ist im Urin aufgefallen?
Kreatinin.
Urinkreatinin und Zucker natürlich.
Glucose?
Glucose.
Sie sehen Protein eventuell durch den Diabetes?
Ja, auch Ritrosiden, Protein.
Vielleicht kann eine Retinopathie entwickelt werden.
Oder?
Ja.
Als bestätigendes Testen führe ich zuerst z.B. Nüchthensucker.
Und kann auch einen Oranglucos- Toleranz-Test durchführen.
Oder Gelegenheit Zucker messen, wenn z.B. über 200 Symptome kommen.
Das ist richtig, aber Sie haben ja schon einen Hund.
Für eine normale Diabetesdiagnose.
Wir müssen erst mal diese Akuzitulation.
Wir müssen natürlich sofort einen Zugang legen.
Und eine Flüssigkeit mit Insulin einsetzen.
Und z.B. pro Kilo können wir eine Unit hinzufügen.
Sehr gut.
Also das heißt, Sie haben hier eine hyperglykämische Entgleisung.
Erstdiagnose. Sie machen eine ausgiebige Diagnostik.
Blutgase messen den Urin. Ultraschall, Leber und Niere machen Sie noch.
VG wäre wichtig. Was sind Ihre Differenzialdiagnosen? Woran denken Sie noch?
Wenn der Patient jetzt kommt und hat Seestörungen.
Eine Hypothyroidin.
Eine Hypothyreose.
Eine Hypothyreose. Und ein Metabolisches Syndrom.
Und Herzinsuffizienz.
Ja gut. Herzinsuffizienz muss man auch mal denken.
Ja natürlich.
Wenn jemand gute Seestörungen hat, woran denkt man noch?
Auf Gehirnprobleme. Z.B. Gehirnzimmern.
Z.B. richtig. Ja.
Z.B. diese kann eine Drucke über Nerveoptikus machen.
Ok.
In der Oxpitalbereich. Oder Oxalapentumoren.
Ein was für Tumor?
Oxipital, Lappen oder...
Ok. Also ein Hirntumor. Was noch?
Ja das ist alles für mich.
Haben die Kollegen vielleicht noch Vorschläge oder andere Ideen, was es sein kann?
Entschuldigung. Vielleicht Multiple Sclerosis.
Ok. Sehr gut. Also an einer neurologischen Erkrankung?
Ja. Eine neurologische. Und ja auch Alter ist nicht sehr alter.
Der ist sehr alter und kann ja junger sein.
Und deswegen können wir Multiple Sclerosis äußern.
Ok. Oder der Vater hat einen hohen Blutdruck.
Vielleicht hat der Patient auch einen hohen Blutdruck.
In der Arteria muss ich auf jeden Fall denken.
Genau. Muss man auch untersuchen. Sehr gut.
Ja wunderbar. Vielen Dank Herr Doktor. Das haben Sie gut gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Die Vorstellung, die Differentialdiagnosen. Sehr gut.
Haben vielleicht die Kollegen noch ein paar Vorschläge oder Ideen?
Oder Anmerkungen? Kritiken?
Alle sind glücklich. Alle sagen Doktor Lokman hat das super toll gemacht.
Vielen Dank.
Er hat die Prüfung bestanden.
Insha'Allah.
Ok. Ja das war sehr gut. Sie waren ruhig. Sie waren langsam.
Haben gute Fragen gestellt.
Auch die Grammatik fand ich gut.
Zu der Mutter haben Sie gesagt, sie litt an Diabetes.
Also eine Vergangenheitsform.
Leidet. Also sehr gut.
Sie haben eine schöne Übersicht gemacht. Gute Fragen gestellt.
Ich glaube Ihre Anfangsdiagnose war auch Diabetes.
Ja. Genau. Dieser Patient ist wirklich gekommen vor zwei Wochen.
Genau. Genauso wie ich es geschildert habe.
Er kam mit Seestörungen.
Und wir hatten vor einem Jahr, da war der HbA1c noch bei 6,1.
Wir hatten keine Therapie. Und jetzt innerhalb von, glaube ich, neun Monaten.
Jetzt hatte im Labor ein HbA1c von 11.
Und was haben Sie gemacht zum Beispiel bei dieser Ketopositose?
Ich habe ihn gleich ins Krankenhaus geschickt.
Er ist schon näher behandelt worden als im Krankenhaus.
Ungefähr eine Woche dort.
Und wir haben ihn jetzt auf Insulin eingestellt.
Klar plus Metformin.
Aber da er sehr übergewichtig ist, will ich ihn vom Insulin wegbekommen.
Ja, eine Tante.
Für diese neueren, diese GLP1-Medikamente, dieses Ozenpic oder Ogarum.
Also das, was den Diabetes behandelt, aber auch gleichzeitig Gewicht abnehmen lässt.
Dass man ihn damit ein bisschen unterstützt.
Und klar, Verlaufskontrolle, Laborkontrolle, Zuckerkontrolle.
Dass der Zucker sich so um den Bereich 110, 120 oder 130 hält.
Jawohl. Ja wunderbar. Vielen Dank.
Und immer noch keine Fragen.
Immer noch keine Fragen. Masha'Allah. Oder?